هنا في هذه الاوقات يتم انتشال مزيد من
الشهداء من تحت منزل عائله خطاب في منطقه
حكر
الجامع حيث تم انتشال في هذه
الاثناء امراه من تحت انقاذ المنزل الذي
تم تدميره قبل قليل من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه
الاسرائيليه نحن في هذه الاثناء في منطقه
حكر الجامع من جديد الغارات الاسرائيليه
تتواصل هنا منزل لعائله خطاب ايضا من جديد
يتم استهدافه قبل قليل اعداد من الشهداء
والمصابين تم نقلهم من هنا باتجاه مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح الغاره
الاسرائيليه كانت قويه جدا هنا حسب شهود
العيان وبحسب المواطنين هذه عاله مدنيه
كانت تجلس بداخل منزلها هنا ولكن تفاجات
في عمليه القصف بدون سابق انذار هنا حسب
ما يتحدث شهود العيان الحمد لله على
سلامتكم الله يسل ايش اللي صار والله اللي
صارحنا قاعدين ساهين لاهين اجينا من
المقبره واجينا بتفا الا صوت قوي جدا
والحدث هذا شايفه امامك وبنقول حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل انتم شيعتكم المجزره اللي قبل
من عائله خطاب الله يفتح عليك شيعنا
المجزره اللي حصلت البارح بعد العشاء وال
وروحنا وصلنا البيت وبنت فاجا بالضربه
الثانيه شهداء واصابات في في شهداء
واصابات الله يرحم الجميع بدون سابق انذار
ولا سابق انذار ولا في شيء وبعدين يعني
كلهم ناس ع لا غادي ولا كلهم على على
البركه زي ما انت شايف الحمد لله رب
العالمين هذا من فضل الله عز وجل ورحمه
الله علينا الحمد لله بقول لك منطقه امنه
ذر البلح منطقه امنه ذر البل والناس بتجي
ترجع عند بعض مساكين هذا بيجي عنده قريب
وهذا بيجي عنده صعب والله في ناس من
الشارع جابوهم والله من الشارع جابوهم
وقعهم عندهم اوهم عشان دير البلح امنه
وهذا الامن يا اخوي افرج ايش اللي صار 14
شهيد عندنا وهي ابن عمنا الثاني هذا عنده
سبعه شهداء كمان ايش بدنا نسوي الامر الى
الله سبحانه وتعالى وما لنا نقول حسبنا
الله ونعم الوكيل اجيت من الدفنه على
القصفه اجينا من الدفنه لقينا القصفه قدام
الغارات الاسرائيليه تزايدت وتيرتها خلال
الساعه الاخيره هنا على دير البلح وايضا
على منطقه حكر الجامح هذه المنطقه التي
تعتبر عدد كبير جدا من النازحين قد لجؤوا
اليها بالاضافه الى اعداد السكان الاصليين
في هذه المنطقه الدمار ق احل بشكل كامل في
هذا المكان قبل قليل ايضا كانت هناك غاره
جويه اسرائيليه على منطقه الزوايده في
شمال دير البلح وهذا الامر ادى الى وقوع
اصابات وشهداء تم وصولهم لمستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح الغارات الاسرائيليه
تتواصل على كل شيء هنا في المحافظه الوسطى
والوير وتيره الغارات الاسرائيليه تتصاعد
ساعه بعد اخرى اشرف ابو عمره
الجزيره دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه m